Let's go to our caller from the seven zero
seven area code.
Who's calling today from seven oh seven eight.
David is dead.
Hey, Devin, what's going on?
Hey, I'm a really longtime listener.
I am in northern California.
I'm a 34 year old single father of a seven
year old who I'm homeschooling right now.
Okay.
And I had one question and two comments.
OK.
My one question is, you know, I'm not a pessimistic
kind of person.
But what is the worst case scenario for our
election this year?
Like, if Trump wins and they take the House
and the Senate are some real trouble.
That is the worst case scenario.
Yeah, the worst.
So the worst case scenario would be a Democrats
don't take the Senate.
Democrats lose control of the House.
Trump gets himself reelected.
He, during his next term, chooses replacements
for Clarence Thomas and Ruth Bader Ginsburg
to the Supreme Court, turns his 300 or however
many judge selections into six hundred and
ushers in a wave of Trump ism in 2022 and
2024 that it takes 20 years to disabuse ourselves
from.
That's the worst case and it's pretty bad.
You know, not only that, but if all that happens,
I just see us as like an American people,
like we're going to fall so short to the view
of the entire world.
Of course.
Like it.
Yeah, I know.
And I just I don't know how to really put
it, but, you know, having been the age, I
mean, I was in a sophomore in high school
when 9/11 happened, and it was a pretty impactful
thing on my life.
But this presidency has really shown how far,
you know, we've fallen even since those times.
Yeah.
And it's just really sad.
It's sad and heartbreaking, though.
The U.S. has become a laughing stock and the
pity of the world.
So we are a laughing stock, but it's actually
gotten so bad that in some places they now
they're not laughing anymore.
They pity us.
And unfortunately, you have a lot of the 60
something million people who voted for Trump
who see that as a badge of honor.
They're emboldened by the fact that people
in other countries think we're out of our
minds.
They think that means we must be doing something
right.
So I'm a distiller from northern California.
We make bytecode whiskey and stuff.
And I've always had a deal with the federal
government and regulations.
Yeah.
And I've always found it to actually be a
really fair system.
If you're willing to do with it, pull up your
end of the deal at this point.
Working with the federal government, it just
seems like they are going so far off the deep
end when it comes to Stephen Mnuchin and policies
when it comes to immigration.
It's just it's almost like I don't recognize
the country I live in anymore.
I'm with you, my wife.
Yeah.
And I've always wanted to, like, you know,
save up money and go vacationing and kind
of go around the world and tour the place
a little bit.
But I don't feel welcome.
Well, yeah.
I mean, right now, it's not only that, it's
also what's going on with Corona virus.
But I understand that.
And that is that that's a major problem.
And I've I've told stories about that before,
and it's so it doesn't feel good, but it doesn't
feel good.
Yeah, good.
Going into work at 4:00 in the morning for
the last 10 years on my local radio station.
Casey, why else would have your show on that
show listening to it?
And I have gone to YouTube to watch you now.
And I really appreciate everything you're
doing and the way you disseminate information.
My favorite kind of news personality out there,
and I just have one more comment.
Yeah.
During the debate, I wish Joe Biden would
tell Trump we're going to make America great
again.
That would be interesting to set the bar now.
Yeah, that'd be amazing.
And I want to get a flu had that says what?
I mean, it's just it's such a weird position
to be in.
But Joe Biden actually had the opportunity
to do it.
And it's just it's a once in a lifetime opportunity
to just change things back around.
And, you know, I really appreciate everything
I do.
And I'm like, so excited.
I always call him for having you take my call.
This is the first time I just.
You're awesome, man.
All right.
Devin from California.
Thank you for the call.
Great to hear from you.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine,
seven, eight area code.
Who's calling today from 978?
I am very Fitzgibbons.
I'm sorry, did you say your name's Brett?
Right.
Yes.
What's going on, Bre?
Well, let me tell you something.
I've I've put in my application to the city
hall for a mail in ballot.
Yeah, well, it was never delivered the by
the post office.
OK, let's back up, Brett.
Where?
So where what part of the country are you
talking about?
You're here in Boston.
On the North Shore.
North Shore.
Okay.
And did you call and ask what's going on with
your ballot?
Yeah, I did.
And that's they always e-mailed them out a
week ago and it was never delivered.
Yeah.
So I actually it took me three weeks to get
mine.
And I when I called, they said and this is
a quote, it's because of what's going on with
the post office, which struck me as very ominous.
So, I mean, I do think, you know, you're talking
about for the September first primary, right?
Yeah.
Which is just now just days away.
I was asking for the mail in ballot for the
presidential.
But they don't rule it.
Wait, wait a second, hold on, let me back
up.
Right.
Are you.
Are you saying you you're waiting on the ballot
for November?
Yes.
Oh, no, they haven't sent those out yet.
There hasn't.
There's still a primary on September 1st.
It's fired.
You shouldn't have gotten the November ballot
yet.
That's normal.
Nobody's gotten it yet.
In Massachusetts.
I've got no doubt.
Now to me.
Did you request the Democratic primary ballot
because you do have to request that.
Yes, I did.
Yes, you did.
OK.
So that's the one I'd be concerned about,
the November one?
Not so much.
It's yeah, it's a problem.
Now, if you don't get it by September 1st,
will you go in and vote in person?
We get what we get early voting right now.
Oh, OK.
I have to get out to vote this week.
You're going to do it.
OK, very good.
Will you?
I mean, listen, it's a mess.
I'm hearing these stories from all over the
country.
Yes, to crime.
Yes.
All right, my friend, Brett, thank you for
the call.
Great to hear from you.
And yet another data point about how bad it
is with a lot of this post office shenanigans
that are going on.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding.
Don't hang up because I'm going right back
to the phones momentarily.